the growing impeachment inquiry
questions are resonating in Ukraine the
country's top prosecutor says he will
review several criminal cases including
some related to the owner of the company
where hunter Buyten worked as Roxana
Saberi reports from Kiev president
Trump's called to investigate the
buttons has catapulted Ukraine's
president into the spotlight Ukraine's
media savvy president is used to cameras
pays the rent but these days he tries to
avoid them when it comes to questions
about state fun were you told that you
had to launch an investigation into the
Biden's or promised an investigation
that was mr. szalinski has said mr.
Trump didn't pressure him to investigate
the Biden's but text messages appear to
show US diplomats promised he could
visit the Oval Office if he announced an
investigation into the Ukrainian natural
gas company buries m'a we're hunter
Biden was on the board and on Friday
Ukraine's new prosecutor general said
Judith will review several past
investigations some involving the owner
of buries m'a though he said no one had
pressured him to do so I've never met or
did you lie never before mr. cilenti had
to deal with this international drama as
president
[Music]
it was a comedian who played a president
on Ukrainian TV his character was a
teacher propelled into the presidency
accidentally the show made him so
popular mr. szalinski launched a
political party named after it servant
of the people winning this year's
presidential election in a landslide
president delenn ski has promised to end
Ukraine's war with Russia and fight
corruption now nearly four and a half
months since the Lenski swept to office
people here in Kiev have mixed feelings
about how he's done so far
some people say his lack of political
experience has been refreshing others
say it's already proven to be a cause
for concern his young men he's mean
politically for Ukraine eats better it
was the stupidest decision this man says
for Ukrainians to elect someone with no
experience in foreign policy presidents
olanski is having to learn fast now that
he's playing a reluctant role in
American politics for CBS this morning
Saturday Roxana Saberi
Kiev